This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. A while back, Gene Atkins heard a funny story from her mother-in-law, Carolyn. The first time I heard it was the only time I heard it. The story took place in their hometown of Hannibal, Missouri, and it involved one of the town's native sons. Lester, Gabba or Gabba or Gabba, however you say his name. Lester Gabba, I'm gonna go with Gabba, was a family friend who had grown up in Hannibal in the early 1900s and then made a name for himself
这里是“99%隐形”，我是罗曼·马尔斯。不久前，吉恩·阿特金斯从她的婆婆卡洛琳那里听到一个有趣的故事。我第一次听到它，也是唯一一次听到它。故事发生在他们的家乡密苏里州汉尼拔，主角是该镇的一位本土名人。莱斯特·加巴，或者怎么发音都行，莱斯特·加巴，我就叫他加巴吧，他是他们家的一个朋友，20世纪初在汉尼拔长大，后来在
in the glamorous world of New York fashion. And Jean's mother-in-law story was about this one time when Gabba came back to town. Lester was visiting Hannibal after having become famous and he was returning with Cynthia. Cynthia was Lester's equally glamorous girlfriend, a socialite who hailed from Manhattan's Upper Cross. And so Gene's mother-in-law's family invited them over for an afternoon tea. Think a room full of women dressed up Hannibal's high
纽约时尚界光鲜亮丽的世界里闯出了名堂。吉恩的婆婆讲的故事，讲的是加巴有一次回到镇上的情景。莱斯特在成名后回到汉尼拔访问，同行的还有辛西娅。辛西娅是莱斯特同样光鲜亮丽的女友，一位来自曼哈顿上东区的名媛。于是吉恩婆婆的一家人邀请他们去喝下午茶。想象一下，一个房间里挤满了穿着汉尼拔上流
society. And given the time and given the importance of the guest and the fact that he was from New York City, it would have been seen as an important social event. And her mother-in-law, who at the time was still a young girl, was given the critical task of providing the guests with snacks, which must have felt like the perfect opportunity to meet this Cynthia that everyone was talking about. So she carefully took a tray of cookies around the room, table to table, person to person. Well, then she offered Cynthia some cookies. Only it turned out there was a problem.
社会服装的女性。考虑到当时的时代背景，客人的重要性，以及他来自纽约市这一事实，这被视为一场重要的社交活动。吉恩的婆婆当时还是个小女孩，她被委以重任，负责为客人们提供点心，这一定让她觉得这是结识这位每个人都在谈论的辛西娅的绝佳机会。于是她小心翼翼地端着一盘饼干在房间里走来走去，从这张桌子到那张桌子，从这个人到那个人。然后她给辛西娅端了一些饼干。结果却发现出了个问题。
Cynthia was unresponsive. And there was a good reason for this. Well, Cynthia, as it turns out, was a mannequin. Until that moment, Jean's mother-in-law had just assumed that Cynthia was a real person. But only because all the grown-ups had been treating Cynthia like a real person. And in fact, when they saw her surprise, the grown-ups just laughed at her reaction, and then continued acting like nothing was out of the ordinary. Everyone at the party just
辛西娅毫无反应。这背后是有充分理由的。原来，辛西娅其实是个假人模特。直到那一刻，吉恩的婆婆还以为辛西娅是个真人。但这只是因为所有的大人都把辛西娅当成真人对待。事实上，当大人们看到她感到惊讶时，只是对她的反应哈哈大笑，然后继续像什么都没发生一样行事。派对上的每个人都
went along with the fact that there was a mannequin present. They gave it a spot at the table. Because Cynthia wasn't just any old mannequin from New York. This wasn't even her first social event. That's reporter Mitchell Johnson. By the time Jean's mother-in-law met her, she had already attended balls, graced the front pages of magazines, and appeared in Hollywood movies. Cynthia was a celebrity. A celebrity at the center of One Man's Life. She was his ticket to fame, and eventually, the object of his obsession.
顺其自然地接受了现场有一个假人模特的事实。他们给它在桌上安排了一个位子。因为辛西娅可不仅仅是纽约来的任何旧假人。这甚至都不是她的第一次社交活动。那是记者米切尔·约翰逊。在吉恩的婆婆见到她时，她已经参加过舞会，登上过杂志头条，还在好莱坞电影中出镜。辛西娅是个名人。一个成为某个人生活重心的名人。她是他通往名气的敲门砖，最终成了他痴迷的对象。
But she was also at the center of a larger story about department stores. They rise, they're fall, and how they forever changed the way we shop. Before online ads, before television, department stores had one major medium with which to display their clothes to the outside world, the window. The arrival of affordable plate glass in the 1800s turned storefronts into advertising spaces.
但她也是百货公司宏大历史的核心：它们的兴衰，以及它们如何永远改变了我们的购物方式。在网络广告和电视出现之前，百货公司向外界展示服装的主要媒介只有一个，那就是橱窗。19世纪廉价平板玻璃的出现，将店面变成了广告空间。
And that's at mannequins, which had earlier mostly been used for fitting clothes to the front of the store. By the early 20th century, there was a new career, window display designer. And what the display designer wants you to do is not just look but to stop. That's the next stage of actually capturing your desire. That's Sarah Schneider. She wrote a book on mannequins and store windows called Vital Mommies. And a lot of it is about this exact moment.
这也催生了假人模特，它们早期主要用于在店面里试穿衣服。到了20世纪初，出现了一个新职业，橱窗陈列设计师。陈列设计师希望你做的不仅仅是看，而是停下脚步。这是真正捕获你欲望的下一阶段。那是萨拉·施耐德。她写了一本关于假人模特和商店橱窗的书，名叫《充满活力的妈妈们》。其中很大一部分内容都与这个确切的时刻有关。
When you're stopped on the street, looking into a window. In the early 1900s, what you would be looking at was a kaleidoscopic collection of things for you to buy. People wanted variety. Very commonly, the window display was simply like this cornucopia of products being presented in the windows to show that the store really did have everything. And the idea was the more you could show, the more you couldn't ice people to come in, because they would see the advantage of being able to shop in one place for everything they needed. And in the early 20th century, if this worked, and you walked into one of the big department stores in New York,
当你驻足街头，凝视橱窗时。在20世纪初，你所看到的是万花筒般的各种待售商品。人们渴望多样性。通常情况下，橱窗陈列就像是一个琳琅满目的产品聚宝盆，向人们展示这家店确实应有尽有。其理念是，你展示的东西越多，就越能吸引人们走进来，因为他们会看到一站式购齐所需所有物品的好处。而在20世纪初，如果这招管用，你走进了纽约的某家大型百货公司，
you'd find some of the most ornate spaces in the city. Merchandise everywhere, wonderful decorations, really kind of opulent displays. That's a lot of stady, a historian at the National Museum of American History. And she says the interiors of department stores were just like their window displays. Jam packed with attractions. The stores featured concert halls, tea rooms, restaurants, and fashion shows replete with champagne. At one point to help sell a line of winter wear,
你会发现这座城市里一些最富丽堂皇的空间。到处都是商品，精美的装饰，简直是一种极其奢华的陈列。那是国家美国历史博物馆的历史学家萨拉·斯塔迪。她说，百货公司的内部装饰就像它们的橱窗陈列一样。塞满了各种吸引人的东西。商场里设有音乐厅、茶室、餐厅以及伴有香槟的时装秀。为了推销某一系列的冬装，
Sachs Fadavanu installed an indoor ski slope. Growing up in small town Hannibal, Missouri, young Glester Gabbard dreamed of entering the luxurious world of these elite department stores. His father was a shopkeeper, and as a boy, he spent most of his free time concocting a labrit displays for the shop's front window, using whatever materials he had at hand.
萨克斯第五大道百货甚至在室内安装了一条滑雪道。在密苏里州汉尼拔的小镇长大的年轻格雷斯特·加巴，梦想着进入这些精英百货公司那奢华的世界。他的父亲是一名店主，作为一名少年，他把大部分空闲时间都用来为商店的前窗精心设计各种复杂的陈列，使用的都是手头现成的材料。
One time, he painted some old soap boxes, black and white, and put them in the window to create the appearance of checkered tiles, anything to give the family business a touch of big city glamour. I know that he and his father had some sort of argument around like a bout display, and he, you know very
有一次，他把一些旧肥皂盒涂成黑白相间，放在橱窗里营造出棋盘格地砖的效果，只要能给家族生意带来一丝大城市的魅力，什么都行。我知道他和父亲曾围绕橱窗陈列大吵过一架，然后他，你知道非常
dramatically said well I I gathered my things and I left. After the fight with his father Lester Gabba left Hannibal for good determined to become a window display designer but when Gabba finally arrived in New York in the early 30s he found that department stores window displays lacking, especially the mannequins. At the time there were two main styles of mannequins. One was a holdover from the 19th century. You would still certainly have these uncannily realistic-looking figures that looked, I would say, kind of like, a bit doubty? They were carved out of wax and made to be extremely lifelike,
戏剧性地说，好吧，我收拾东西离开了。与父亲大吵一架后，莱斯特·加巴永远离开了汉尼拔，决心成为一名橱窗陈列设计师，但当加巴在30年代初终于抵达纽约时，他发现百货公司的橱窗陈列毫无新意，尤其是假人模特。当时主要有两种风格的假人模特。一种是19th世纪的遗留产物。你当然还是会看到那些诡异逼真的形象，我想说，它们看起来有点，怎么说呢，有点老土？它们是用蜡雕刻出来的，做得极其逼真，
often with real human hair and eyelashes. On the hottest days, they would sometimes melt in the store window. The other main style of mannequin at the time was a more recent invention from the 20s. These were Art Deco, abstract. Think human figures turned into modernist Picasso-like shapes. When Lester arrived, they would still have been considered very sophisticated and avant-garde. But they didn't necessarily have like
通常还带有真正的头发和睫毛。在最热的日子里，它们有时会在商店的橱窗里融化。当时另一种主要的假人模特风格是20年代的最新发明。这些是装饰风艺术风格的抽象作品。想想被变成现代主义毕加索式形状的人体形态。当莱斯特到达时，这些仍然被认为是非常高雅和前卫的。但它们不一定具有
personality. Gabba was part of a new generation of window designers who thought there must be a way to do better. His aesthetic opinions were that windows needed a facelift, and the windows in themselves needed personality, along with the women who inhabited those windows, the mannequins. So in 1932, Gabba wrote into a trade publication calling for a revolution in mannequin design. In the article, he argued that mannequins should embody an ideal. Gabba wrote, put Joan Crawford in a store case, and even husbands will want to go window shopping.
个性。加巴是新一代橱窗设计师的一员，他们认为必须有更好的方法来做到这一点。他的审美品味是，橱窗需要翻新，橱窗本身需要个性，与那些居住在橱窗里的女性——假人模特——一起。因此，在1932年，加巴在一家行业刊物上撰文，呼吁进行假人模特设计的革命。他在文章中辩称，假人模特应该体现一种理想。加巴写道，把琼·克劳馥放在商店的橱窗里，连丈夫们都会想去逛橱窗。
So he's trying to find that balance between how do you make the mannequin look realistic enough to be relatable and how do you make her an embodiment of the figure that women wish they were to make her an embodiment of the figure that women wish they were to make her desirable? So, Wingaba was commissioned by Saxveth Avenue to create a new line of window displays. He saw it as an opportunity to make his perfect mannequin. And because he wanted it to embody this kind of plausible ideal, he decided to model his mannequins off a group of people who were idolized in real life. New York society women, socialites.
所以他试图在以下两者之间找到平衡：如何让假人模特看起来足够真实以便引起共鸣，以及如何将她塑造为女性渴望成为的身材的化身，从而让她具有吸引力？因此，当加巴受萨克斯第五大道百货委托创作一系列新的橱窗陈列时。他将其视为打造自己完美假人模特的机会。由于他希望它体现这种貌似合理的理想，他决定以现实生活中被奉为偶像的一群人为蓝本制作他的假人模特。纽约社交名媛，上流社会女性。
Gabba began to seek out these socialites. Imagine the daughter of a steel magnate then, perhaps a banking aress, and have them pose for him in his studio. One by one, they sat for Gabba. And by hand, he sculpted a life-size version of each woman out of clay. He would then use the clay figure to make a mold, and then use the mold to make a mannequin. When he was finished, he called his new line of mannequins, Gava Girls. Gava Girls didn't quite look like mannequins due today. They were made out of a heavy plaster material instead of plastic, and they still had distinct facial features, including eyes and lips that were painted on.
加巴开始寻找这些社交名媛。想象一下当时的钢铁大亨之女，或许还有银行家女继承人，让她们在他的工作室里为他摆姿势。她们一个接一个地为加巴做模特。他亲手用粘土雕刻出每个女人的真人大小版本。然后他用这个粘土人偶制作模具，再用模具制作假人模特。当他完成时，他将他的新系列假人模特命名为“加巴女孩”。加巴女孩看起来并不完全像今天的假人模特。它们是用厚重的石膏材料而不是塑料制成的，并且仍然具有鲜明的面部特征，包括画上去的眼睛和嘴唇。
But they were no longer the hyper-realistic wax figures that had come before. Instead, they had just enough detail to give each one its own personality. One or two had some freckles, one had a beauty mark, so there were ways in which the inanimate woman would communicate part of her own self. But out of all the Gava girls, Lester began to fixate on one in particular. A mannequin who he would come to believe was different from the others. A mannequin he simply called Cynthia. the others. We know virtually nothing about the real-life person Gabba used as a model for Cynthia, except possibly a name, Cynthia Wells. We don't even know how she came to model for him or which of her actual features were used for the final mold and which he just invented.
但它们不再是以前那种超级逼真的蜡像了。相反，它们拥有恰到好处的细节，赋予每个人独特的个性。一两个有雀斑，一个有美人痣，因此这个没有生命的女人可以通过某种方式传达她自己的一部分。但在所有的加巴女孩中，莱斯特开始特别执着于其中一个。一个他开始相信与其他人不同的假人模特。一个他简单地称之为辛西娅的假人模特。其他人。我们对加巴用作辛西娅原型的现实生活中的人物几乎一无所知，可能除了一个名字，辛西娅·韦尔斯。我们甚至不知道她是如何成为他的模特的，也不知道她的哪些真实特征被用于最终的模具，哪些是他凭空捏造的。
But once Gabba saw the result, he was just totally astounded. Right away, Lester could see that Cynthia the mannequin had a very particular look. She was quite slender, very light, colored peach skin, blonde hair, in a wig, very faint, angular jawline, very small, pointed, slightly upturned nose. But it was more than just her physical features. It was how they all added up into a certain kind of attitude. It was this wonderful combination of like New York snobbery and total, like, quiet humility that you know made her appear very inviting and very sweet but also like she had a lot of secrets. I can't describe it beyond that but the gaze could kind of cut through you. Cynthia's persona was perched ever so delicately between warm intimacy and cool distance.
但一旦加巴看到结果，他简直惊呆了。莱斯特一眼就能看出，假人模特辛西娅有一种非常独特的外表。她相当苗条，肤色非常白皙透亮，戴着金色假发，下颌线条非常柔和且有棱角，鼻子非常小巧、尖尖且微微上翘。但不仅仅是她的身体特征那么简单。而是所有这些特征如何汇聚成一种特定的态度。这是一种奇妙的结合，既有纽约式的势利，又有完全安静的谦逊，你知道，这让她显得非常平易近人、甜美动人，但也仿佛深藏着许多秘密。除了这些我无法再做更多描述，但那种眼神仿佛能看穿你。辛西娅的个人魅力在温暖的亲密感和冷酷的距离感之间保持着微妙的平衡。
She was the embodiment of Gabba's long sought after ideal. And that's when Lester Gabba came up with an even more ambitious plan. It would be a marketing scheme involving Cynthia to help promote his new line, one that would require him to turn his own life into a kind of never-ending display. He decided to get a Cynthia built for himself, for his home and for his own life. Lester Gabba began living with Cynthia, the man again, full time, and by living with Cynthia, I mean living with Cynthia. Visitors to Lester's apartment would arrive to discover
她是加巴苦苦追寻的理想的化身。就在那时，莱斯特·加巴想出了一个更加雄心勃勃的计划。这将是一个涉及辛西娅的营销计划，旨在帮助推广他的新产品线，这需要他把自己的生活变成一种永无止境的展览。他决定为自己、为他的家、为他自己的生活定制一个辛西娅。莱斯特·加巴开始全职与假人模特辛西娅一起生活，我说的“和辛西娅一起生活”就是字面意思。来访莱斯特公寓的访客会发现
Cynthia sitting on a couch. Perhaps deeply engaged in a book or listening to a record, like a real person. So he lived with Cynthia for a while. And when he had friends over, friends would remark about Cynthia. And it somehow came to him to start to take Cynthia out with him socially and to treat her as his date at social occasions.
辛西娅正坐在沙发上。也许正全神贯注地读着一书，或者像真人一样听着唱片。所以他和辛西娅一起生活了一段时间。当他邀请朋友来家里时，朋友们会对辛西娅评头论足。不知怎么的，他萌生了开始带辛西娅一起外出社交的想法，并在社交场合把她当作自己的女伴。
Lester Gabba began to be seen out on the town with Cynthia. When he arrived at a location, he would set up her torso and limbs into various believable poses, just like a window display, only not in a window. Sitting at bars, sitting in theaters, pretending that she had some sort of opinion that she wanted to share. And so he would simply explain, you know, that the reason she's not saying anything is that she has learneditis. But that's not even the strangest part. Because in every place Lester appeared with her, Cynthia was a hit.
莱斯特·加巴开始带着辛西娅在城里出没。当他到达一个地方时，他会把她的躯干和四肢摆成各种逼真的姿势，就像橱窗陈列一样，只不过不在橱窗里。坐在酒吧里，坐在剧院里，假装她有什么想要分享的见解。于是他就会简单地解释说，你知道，她之所以不说话是因为她得了失语症。但这还不是最奇怪的部分。因为在莱斯特带她出现的每一个地方，辛西娅都大受欢迎。
People just wanted to be around her. Increasingly, both friends and strangers started playing along, talking to Cynthia, telling her the latest gossip, laughing at an imaginary joke, and soon word began to spread. You know, this is Lester Gabba, he has a new partner in town, and she is inanimate, but she is beautiful. Cynthia started getting invited to all the most exclusive parties and showing up in the society papers. City tabloids began reporting on her every move, And it wasn't long before other people in the fashion world
人们就是想和她待在一起。越来越的，朋友和陌生人都开始配合演戏，跟辛西娅说话，告诉她最新的八卦，对着一个想象中的笑话发笑，不久消息便开始传开。你知道，这就是莱斯特·加巴，他在城里有了个新伴侣，她虽然没有生命，但她很美。辛西娅开始收到所有最顶级派对的邀请，并出现在社交版面上。城市小报开始报道她的一举一动，不久之后，时尚界的其他人也
capitalized on her growing fame. It was a really great way to communicate fashion trends. So lots of designers and lots of display directors really thought if I could get Cynthia in the latest Lily Dashet suit and smart little hat, I will get better sales." Various businesses began sending Cynthia free things. She received free dresses from sacks, diamonds from Tiffany's, tickets to the Metropolitan
利用了她日益增长的名气。这是传达时尚潮流的一种非常棒的方式。因此，许多设计师和许多陈列总监真的认为，如果我能让辛西娅穿上最新款的莉莉·达切特西装并戴上精致的小帽子，我就会获得更好的销量。”各种企业开始给辛西娅送免费的东西。她收到了萨克斯百货的免费连衣裙、蒂芙尼的钻石、大都会
Opera, and when she showed up in tabloids, she was wearing designer clothes. By the end of the 30s, Cynthia had become wildly famous. In 1938 at her peak, she was featured in a Hollywood movie called Artists and Models of Broad. It's a musical starring Jack Benny. In one of the numbers, all the characters are dancing in a department store. And there, in the background, is Cynthia.
歌剧院的门票，当她出现在小报上时，身上穿的都是设计师服装。到了30年代末，辛西娅已经变得红极一时。1938年，在她名气的巅峰时期，她出演了一部名为《百老汇的艺术家和模特》的好莱坞电影。这是一部由杰克·本尼主演的音乐剧。在其中一个歌舞段落中，所有角色都在百货公司里跳舞。而在背景中，正是辛西娅。
Lester Gabba's hair brain scheme had worked. Gabba Girl Manicans could now be found in all the big department stores, and Cynthia was a household name. Although there was one appearance by Cynthia which pulled back the Curtain on Leicester's act just a little bit, it's in a life magazine article from 1937. The article is full of images of Cynthia's busy day. Sitting next to Lester, reading her fan mail, writing on top of a double-decker tour bus in Manhattan. But then, toward the end of the piece, there's this one photo.
莱斯特·加巴这个异想天开的计划成功了。加巴女孩假人模特现在可以在所有的大型百货公司找到，辛西娅也成了家喻户晓的名字。不过，辛西娅有一次亮相稍微拉开了莱斯特表演的帷幕，那是在1937年的一期《生活》杂志文章中。这篇文章充满了辛西娅忙碌一天的照片。和莱斯特坐在一起，阅读她的粉丝来信，坐在曼哈顿双层观光巴士的车顶上。但随后，在文章快结束时，有这样一张照片。
And it's quite arresting. It's a picture of a series of black body bags. And we're told in the caption that it contains parts of Cynthia and it's where she like goes to sleep at night. So it's like you know there's this morbid aspect to this that when it's time for her to perform again out in public Lester her puppet master can just take all of her parts out and reassemble her and she's ready to perform again. Even as the public went along with the gag, Gabbas contemporaries always wondered
而且相当引人注目。这是一张一系列黑色尸袋的照片。我们在图片说明中得知，里面装的是辛西娅的身体部件，也是她晚上睡觉的地方。所以你知道这有一种病态的方面，当她准备好再次公开表演时，她的木偶师莱斯特可以把她的所有部件拿出来重新组装，然后她就准备好再次表演了。尽管公众顺应了这个恶作剧，但加巴的同时代人总是怀疑
whether his dedication to his puppet hinted at motivations beyond publicity. For starters, it was clear that Lester loved the status that came with Cynthia. He could often be seen about town with Broadway stars, clothing designers, and jewelers like Harry Winston. It was also around this time that he became best friends with the famous stage and film director Vincent Manelli. Later the father of Liza Manelli and the husband of Judy Garland. Gabba didn't need to play around with a window display anymore to imagine living like
他对木偶的执着是否暗示着宣传之外的动机。首先，很明显莱斯特喜欢伴随辛西娅而来的地位。人们经常看到他在城里与百老汇明星、服装设计师以及像哈里·温斯顿这样的珠宝商厮混。也正是在这个时候，他成了著名舞台和电影导演文森特·明内利的好友。后来成为莉莎·明内利的父亲和朱迪·加兰的丈夫。加巴再也不需要摆弄橱窗陈列来想象过上
a socialite. He was a socialite now. As long as he kept Cynthia on his arm. But people also wondered if Cynthia was Leicester's way of hiding another part of his life, in plain sight. Especially when they began to suspect that Gabba's friendship with Vincent Manelli had developed into something more. There was mention that they would show up at parties together.
名媛般的生活了。他现在就是个名媛。只要他让辛西娅挽着他的胳膊。但人们也怀疑，辛西娅是否只是莱斯特在大庭广众之下隐藏他生活另一部分的一种方式。特别是当他们开始怀疑加巴与文森特·明内利的友谊已经发展成某种更深厚的关系时。有人提到他们会一起出现在派对上。
There was also rumors that they both showed up at a party wearing a bit of rouge. Manelli's family has denied the rumors, but several Manelli biographers insist they were true. That Lester and Vincent were lovers. And many people saw Cynthia as Lester's way of diverting attention from the relationship. Like Cynthia was basically the epitome of a beard, a distraction. But when put in a larger context, it becomes clear Cynthia was never just a beard, or even just a way for a GABA to live out of fantasy.
还有传言说他们俩都涂了一点胭脂出现在派对上。明内利的家人否认了这些传言，但几位明内利的传记作家坚称这是真的。莱斯特和文森特曾是恋人。许多人认为辛西娅是莱斯特转移对这段关系注意力的手段。就像辛西娅基本上是“挡箭牌”的化身，是一种分散注意力的东西。但放在更大的背景下，很明显辛西娅从来不只是一个挡箭牌，甚至不只是加巴实现幻想的一种方式。
By reflecting a new ideal, she also helped lead a fundamental change in the way clothes were about to be marketed. Because in the middle decades of the 20th century, it wasn't just the mannequins that were changing. It was the window displays themselves. Here's Sarah again. Display was moving from products being all kind of globbed in together to a more artistic and selective kind of presentation and so all of that was changing in GABA's time too. In the early window displays from the 1800s, it was still all about the products. But then store displays started becoming less about selling specific things. Instead,
通过反映一种新的理想，她还引领了服装营销方式的根本变革。因为在20世纪的中期几十年里，改变的不仅仅是假人模特。橱窗陈列本身也在改变。萨拉再次出场。陈列正从各种产品堆砌在一起转变为更具艺术性和选择性的展示方式，因此在加巴的时代，所有这些都在发生变化。在19th世纪的早期橱窗陈列中，重点仍然全是产品。但随后商店陈列开始不再那么注重销售特定商品。相反，
what you're selling is the aura around the product. By the 1960s, Sarah says this kind of marketing had fully taken over. But you can see the beginnings of it in the 30s when Lester Gabba and his contemporaries were working. They used stage lighting, elaborate props and decorations. It was an art. All aimed at creating this aura of desirability
你卖的是产品周围的光环。到了20世纪60年代，萨拉说这种营销方式已经全面占据主导地位。但你可以从30年代莱斯特·加巴和他的同时代人工作时看到它的萌芽。他们使用舞台灯光、精致的道具和装饰。这是一门艺术。其目的全都是为了在商店及其产品周围营造这种令人向往的光环。
around the store and its products. And mannequins played a key part. A mannequin like Cynthia, both relatable and idealized, in other words, a character was perfectly suited to this new storytelling task, particularly in the depths of the Great Depression. She represents a chance to live a life that is free of want. She doesn't have to be anything but beautiful.
而假人模特扮演了关键角色。像辛西娅这样的假人模特，既接地气又被理想化，换句话说，一个角色完美契合了这一新的讲故事任务，特别是在大萧条的低谷时期。她代表着过上一种衣食无忧的生活的机会。她除了美丽之外什么都不需要做。
She has a man doting on her, and she's able to wear the finest garments. So in a way, she's quite aspirational for women of the 30s who were in many cases living lives that were nothing like this. With Cynthia, Leicester was able to tell a story so big that it left the story entirely, and entered real life. The whole world had become this window, allowing him to live inside a fantasy, of wealth, of celebrity, of access, over which he had total control. But then, at the height of Cynthia's fame, the US entered World War II.
有一个男人对她百依百顺，她还能穿上最华丽的衣服。所以在某种程度上，对于30年代的女性来说，她是非常令人向往的，而她们在许多情况下过着与此截然不同的生活。有了辛西娅，莱斯特能够讲出一个如此宏大的故事，以至于它脱离了故事本身，进入了现实生活。整个世界都成了这个橱窗，让他能够生活在一个财富、名望、特权交织的幻想之中，而这一切都在他的完全掌控之下。然而，就在辛西娅名声达到顶峰时，美国卷入了第二次世界大战。
Lester was conscripted, and he had to leave Cynthia behind. No one is entirely sure what happened next, but the story goes that Lester shipped her back to Hannibal to stay with his mother, where he left strict instructions that she continued to be treated like a real person. Which apparently were followed, because one day in 1942, she was relaxing at the local beauty salon. And she slipped from a beauty salon chair and shattered. And this is where the story gets a little darker.
莱斯特应征入伍，他不得不留下辛西娅。没有人确切知道接下来发生了什么，但传言说莱斯特把她运回汉尼拔和他的母亲同住，他在那里留下了严格的指示，要求继续把她当作真人对待。这些指示显然得到了遵守，因为在1942年的一天，她正在当地的美容院放松。结果她从美容院的椅子上滑落并摔碎了。故事在这里变得有点黑暗。
It just quickly goes from being funny to odd to wait a second. Cherry Magged is a playwright and a professor at NYU who wrote a play about Lester and Cynthia called the GABA Girl. After coming across the Life Magazine profile and she became particularly interested in Cynthia's afterlife, all the things that happened after she fell from the chair.
它迅速从有趣变得古怪，再到“等等”。雪莉·马格德是纽约大学的剧作家兼教授，她写了一部关于莱斯特和辛西娅的名为《加巴女孩》的戏剧。在偶然发现《生活》杂志的专题报道后，她对辛西娅的“来世”——她从椅子上摔下来之后发生的所有事情——产生了浓厚的兴趣。
When he came home from the war, Lester Gabba apparently believed that everything could go on as before. He had another Cynthia made. But post-war America with its turn towards middle-class consumerism and suburban living just wasn't interested in this new Cynthia. The press ignored her and luster. It definitely seemed more personally important to him than it did to everyone else. You know, I mean, I think at a certain point it just becomes a parlor trick or like a footnote. And for him, it was, I mean, I don't know like he got invitations that he would have never received.
当他从战争中回家时，莱斯特·加巴显然认为一切都可以像以前一样继续下去。他又定制了一个辛西娅。但战后的美国及其向中产阶级消费主义和郊区生活的转变，对这个新辛西娅根本不感兴趣。媒体忽视了她和莱斯特。这对他个人的重要性显然远超对其他所有人的重要性。你知道，我的意思是，我认为在某个特定时刻，它最终只变成了一个杂耍把戏或一个脚注。对他来说，我是说，我不知道，就像他得到了他永远不会收到的邀请一样。
And then they stopped. But a lot of Stady says, Lester refused to believe it was over. Sometimes it's really difficult for an individual when they get so much affirmation about something to separate themselves from the project or to know when to quit. It doesn't appear that Lester ever went so far as to believe Cynthia was an actual person, but it was as if he was no longer in on the joke. He just couldn't believe that Cynthia had been a fad. Even as late as the 1950s, he was still trying to get her back into the limelight,
然后它们就停止了。但萨拉·斯塔迪说，莱斯特拒绝相信这一切已经结束。有时，当一个人对某件事获得如此多的肯定时，很难将自己与这个项目剥离开来，或者不知道何时该收手。莱斯特似乎从没走到认为辛西娅是个真人的地步，但感觉就像他不再明白这个笑话了。他只是不相信辛西娅只是一阵潮流。直到20世纪50年代末，他仍在试图让她重回聚光灯下，
this time, with a new plan. To have her wired so that she could move and that her mouth could move because he wanted to create a television show for her. The idea was to rig Cynthia with an electronic speaker system so that it would seem like she was talking. If he could get her to talk, Gabba thought he could get her a talk show. Gabba spent $10,000 trying and trying to make Cynthia into a talking automaton. As if all he needed to do was to make her a little more real, then everything would go back
这一次，有了一个新计划。给她接上电线，让她的身体和嘴巴都能动，因为他想为她制作一个电视节目。这个想法是用电子扬声器系统装备辛西娅，让她看起来像是在说话。如果能让她说话，加巴认为他就能为她争取到一个脱口秀节目。加巴花了一万美元，不断尝试将辛西娅变成一个会说话的自动机。仿佛他只需要让她再真实一点，一切就会回到
to the way it was. But the new and improved Cynthia didn't make any sense. All the words sounded garbled. The networks lost interest, and the television show never went anywhere. By then most people had forgotten all about the original GABA girls. And Vincent Manelli, GABA's rumored lover, had moved to Hollywood, leaving Lester alone in New York. So those facts combined just suggested a loss of touch with reality.
原来的样子。但这个崭新改进版的辛西娅却毫无逻辑。所有的话听起来都含糊不清。各大电视网失去了兴趣，这个电视节目最终也不了了之。到那时，大多数人已经把最初的加巴女孩忘得精光。而文森特·明内利，加巴传闻中的恋人，已经搬去了好莱坞，只留下莱斯特孤身一人在纽约。所以这些事实结合起来，只表明他与现实脱节了。
He had no touch with the reality. He created his own reality. This is Morton Miles. He met Lester in New York after the whole Cynthia Fair in the 60s, and they hit it off. Oh yes, he was a lot of fun. He was the most creative person anybody ever knew, totally, totally self-interested. But you would take it from him
他与现实毫无接触。他创造了自己的现实。这是莫顿·迈尔斯。他在60年代“辛西娅风波”过后在纽约结识了莱斯特，两人一见如故。哦是的，他非常有意思。他是任何人所知道的最具创造力的人，完全、彻底地以自我为中心。但你会原谅他，
because he had a lot to offer. They met on Fire Island. At that point at least, Lester's sexuality wasn't a question. Lester was never very shy as a day person. He was there all the time. Gabba had turned to teaching design at a local college and writing a column about fashion display in women's wear daily And Morton was also in the fashion business. He was a clothing designer.
因为他有很多值得称道的地方。他们在火岛相遇。至少在那个时候，莱斯特的性取向已经不是什么秘密了。莱斯特在白天一直表现得很坦然。他一直都在那里。加巴转而在当地一所大学教设计，并为《女装日报》撰写关于时尚陈列的专栏。而莫顿也从事时尚行业。他是一名服装设计师。
Jackie Kennedy actually wore one of Morton's dresses as first lady. And one day Lester saw the photo of Mrs. Kennedy in Morton's dress. And he said, oh, that would have really worked for Cynthia. This was one of the few times Morton remembers Lester bringing up Cynthia at all. For the most part, he wouldn't talk about it. He didn't like people joking about her. Oh, no, oh, no, no. Cynthia was not a joke. In fact, he apparently had been laughed at so much doing this.
杰奎琳·肯尼迪作为第一夫人时确实穿过莫顿的一条裙子。有一天，莱斯特看到了肯尼迪夫人穿着莫顿裙子的照片。他说，哦，这套衣服对辛西娅来说肯定也很合适。这是莫顿记忆中莱斯特少数几次主动提起辛西娅的时刻之一。大多数时候，他绝口不提。他不喜欢别人拿她开玩笑。哦，不，哦，不，不。辛西娅绝不是个笑话。事实上，他显然因为做这件事被嘲笑过很多次，
That, no, no, Cynthia was something he was very serious about That she was a creation of his But Lester's friends had a hard time taking Cynthia as seriously as he did the world had moved on It was just like now where something is a hot topic and at last about 27 seconds and then they go on to the next hot topic, well it was no different than except it was just a little bit slower. So Lester Cynthia was still an oddity, people would still talk about it, but he was the oddity, not Cynthia.
以至于，不，不，辛西娅是他非常认真对待的事情，她是他的创造物。但莱斯特的朋友们很难像他那样认真对待辛西娅，世界已经向前看了。这就好比现在有些事情是个热门话题，持续大约27秒钟，然后人们就转向下一个热门话题，这没有什么不同，只是节奏稍微慢了一点。所以莱斯特的辛西娅仍然是个异类，人们依然会谈论它，但他是那个异类，而不是辛西娅。
Morton says Lester always had one foot in a world of his own creation. He made grand pronouncements about the fashion scene or European culture with so much conviction that they almost sounded true, but it weren't. Even at the end of his life, Morton says Lester was still that small town boy from Hannibal, Missouri, trying to fake it till he made it in the big city. See, Lester had a lot of the thoughts that had to do with unreal things that he made real, but he couldn't make them real any longer. Lester Gabbadide in 1987, by which time unique painstakingly crafted plaster mannequins like Cynthia had gone out of fashion, they were too expensive to make, too difficult to move.
莫顿说，莱斯特总是有一只脚踏在他自己创造的世界里。他对时尚界或欧洲文化发表宏论时信心满满，听起来几乎像真的，但其实不然。莫顿说，即使在生命的尽头，莱斯特依然是那个来自密苏里州汉尼拔的小镇男孩，试图在大城市里假装成功，直到真正成功。你看，莱斯特有许多想法都与他虚构并使其成真的不真实事物有关，但他再也无法让它们成真了。莱斯特·加巴于1987年去世，当时像辛西娅那样精心制作的石膏假人模特已经过时了，它们制作成本太高，移动起来也太困难。
No one knows what happened to Cynthia. In one interview, Gabbas says he took her down to a friend's attic in the East Village, where he left her to sit and gather dust. And the rest of the Gabbas girls are unaccounted for it too. I like to imagine all the Gavagirls that must be tucked away in the basements of department stores forgotten, and all the store clerks up above, with no idea that the mannequin they've abandoned was once a socialite, that she once looked out over Fifth Avenue, watching the crowds gaze up at her as they dreamed of a better life. Up next we learn about the store that's the polar opposite of the opulent 5th Avenue department store, the dollar store.
没有人知道辛西娅后来怎么样了。在一次采访中，加巴说他把她搬到了东村一个朋友的阁楼里，任由她在那里静静积灰。至于其他的加巴女孩，也下落不明。我喜欢想象所有那些必然被塞进百货公司地下室被遗忘的加巴女孩，以及楼上那些店员，他们全然不知他们抛弃的这个假人模特曾是一位社交名媛，她曾俯瞰第五大道，看着人群抬头凝视着她，心中怀揣着对更美好生活的梦想。接下来我们将了解与富丽堂皇的第五大道百货公司截然相反的商店——一元店。
After this. The store you're about to hear was originally broadcast in November 2016. So here we are in the 99 cent store in West Oakland. Go into any dollar store in the United States and you'll find the same kind of stuff. They've already got the Christmas stuff out and like Santa stuff everywhere. Little Santa booties that you can put on your baby. A little Santa costume that you can put on a wine bottle. In US dollar stores there are grocery items and cleaning products and some of them are name
广告之后见。你即将听到的节目最初于2016年11月播出。所以现在我们来到了西奥克兰的99美分商店。走进美国任何一家一元店，你都会发现类似的东西。他们已经把圣诞节的东西摆出来了，到处都是圣诞老人相关的商品。你可以套在宝宝身上的小圣诞老人靴子。可以套在酒瓶上的小圣诞老人服装。在美国的一元店里，有杂货、清洁用品，其中一些是知名
brand items. But then there's this other category of things for sale. Little bags of plastic festive gourds, a slotted spoon. It's just yeah everything, everything's like, this doesn't have a brand name, like, where is it from? Toys and jewelry and knick knacks that seem to have a sort of generic cheapness to them. Lufas. To the very generic-looking razors.
品牌的商品。但随后还有另一类待售商品。一小袋塑料节日葫芦、带缝隙的勺子。没错，一切，一切都像，这个没有品牌名字，这到底是从哪来的？玩具、珠宝和小摆设，似乎都带着一种千篇一律的廉价感。浴球。看起来非常普通的剃须刀。
Little fake plants. Do I want this chocolate toothpaste? I don't think so, but... Dollar stores aren't just a US phenomenon. They're in Australia and the UK. They're in the Middle East and in Mexico. They're all over the world. And a lot of that stuff, that generic cheap stuff
小假植物。我想要这款巧克力牙膏吗？我觉得不想，但是……一元店不仅仅是美国的现象。它们在澳大利亚和英国也有。它们在中东和墨西哥也有。它们遍布世界各地。其中很多商品，那些摆在这些商店货架上的普通廉价商品，都来自同一个地方。中国的一个市场，叫义乌市场。那个超级巨大、无边无际、所有这些东西的源头，绵延数英里，到处都是这样的小店铺。
that lines the shelves of these stores comes from one place. A market in China called the FUTAN market. The big, big, and big where all this stuff comes from, it goes on for miles, from miles and miles of just these tiny little stores. That's documentary filmmaker Daniel Wheeling. The FUTIEN market is about 43 million square feet, or around 10 times the size of the Mall of America. You could enter the market and walk around it for
那是纪录片导演丹尼尔·惠林。义乌市场大约有4300万平方英尺，大约是美国购物中心的10倍。你可以进入这个市场并在里面逛上
days and never see the same stall twice. Daniel and his co-producer, Tobias Anderson Ockervlem, made a documentary film called Bulkland about the FUTION market and the city in China where it's located. Iwu. There's about two million people here completely dedicated to making this stuff for us, but no one's ever heard of it. The city of Iwu is about 200 miles southwest of Shanghai. It's a market city, so it's quite vibrant in parts, but it's not an incredibly livable city and incredibly lovely green city. It turned from a sort of bucolic mountain town to what kind of seems a cookie cutter industrial
几天，却绝不会看到重复的摊位。丹尼尔和他的联合制片人托比亚斯·安德森·奥克弗勒姆拍摄了一部名为《大宗地带》的纪录片，记录了义乌市场及其所在的中国城市。义乌。这里大约有两百万人的生活完全围绕着为我们制造这些东西，但从来没有人听说过它。义乌市位于上海西南约200英里处。它是一个商贸城市，所以有些地方非常有活力，但它并不是一个极其适宜居住、极其可爱的绿色城市。它从一个田园牧歌般的小山城变成了现在这种看似千篇一律的工业
city now. In the late 1970s, Communist China began to open itself up to capitalism. It would no longer be illegal to run private businesses in China. The province of Jojiang, where Iwu is located, had a history of being a center for trade, and the people there were eager to join the new economy. The village has spent all their sort of life savings on cheap industrial equipment, and started producing items that were really easy to make, playing cards, or Christmas decorations, or wooden toys. And soon, a market opened up the city of Iwoo to sell these items.
城市。20世纪70年代末，中国开始走向对外开放。在中国经营私人企业不再违法。义乌所在的浙江省有着贸易中心的悠久历史，那里的居民渴望加入新的经济大潮。全村人把他们所有的积蓄都花在了廉价的工业设备上，开始生产那些非常容易制造的物品，比如扑克牌、圣诞装饰品或木制玩具。不久之后，义乌市开办了一个市场来销售这些商品。
The market is just a street market. People started making Christmas decorations and there's arts and crafts. More and more people started to come to this market and that's how it's grown up. This is Nigel Crop. He's a British trader who lives and works in Iwoo and he originally came to this city just to have an adventure in Teach English. So I started teaching at this English training centre, and I was teaching adults, and they were factory bosses and trading company bosses. So little did they know I was teaching them English, but at the same time, they were teaching me how to do the business here, how it all
这个市场最初只是个街头市场。人们开始制作圣诞装饰品，还有工艺美术品。越来越多的人开始来到这个市场，它就是这样发展起来的。这是奈杰尔·克罗普。他是一名英国商人，在义乌生活和工作，他最初来这座城市只是为了寻求冒险并教英语。于是我开始在这个英语培训中心教书，我教的是成年人，他们是工厂老板和贸易公司老板。所以他们不知道我在教他们英语，但与此同时，他们也在教我如何在这里做生意，这一切是如何
worked. I just do day trips to the food market and then you show me around. The street markets grew and grew and eventually came to encompass four huge buildings connected by sky bridges and roads and parking lots. And each of the buildings is divided into different products. You'll have the jewelry building, the toy building, the art and crafts building, and the clothing building.
运作的。我只是去福田市场进行一日游，然后你带我四处转转。街头市场不断发展壮大，最终演变成四个由空中连廊、道路和停车场连接起来的巨大建筑群。每座建筑都按不同的产品进行划分。你会看到饰品大楼、玩具大楼、工艺美术大楼和服装大楼。
Every day thousands of foreign traders visit this massive market in Iwu. They're haggling in Chinese, looking for things to buy and bulk that they can sell to dollar stores and other vendors in their home countries. Once you get inside it's a lot different to a normal shopping center or shopping mall. It's thousands and thousands of market stalls. These market stalls are about 5 by 5 feet. So usually run by one person or two people and they're sitting in their surrounded by their products. And none of the products are for sale. You can't go in there and say, I want one key ring.
每天都有成千上万的外商来到义乌这个巨大的市场。他们用中文讨价还价，寻找可以批量购买的商品，以便卖给自己祖国的一元店和其他供应商。一旦你走进去，它和普通的购物中心或商场有很大不同。这里有成千上万个市场摊位。这些摊位大约是5英尺见方。通常由一个人或两个人经营，他们坐在里面，周围都是自己的产品。而且所有的产品都是非卖品。你不能走进去说，我想要一个钥匙扣。
You have to go in and say, I want 1,500 key rings. That's exactly the kind of volume Nigel, the British trader who lives in EWU, is looking for money heads to the market. And we need to find generic animals. OK, ocean animals is OK. Also gecko, lizard. We go to the market and the supplier will give us a price. And then we do the ordering.
你必须走进去说，我想要1500个钥匙扣。这正是住在义乌的英国商人奈杰尔在前往市场时寻找的那种交易量。我们需要寻找普通的动物。好的，海洋动物可以。还有壁虎、蜥蜴。我们去市场，供应商会给我们一个价格。然后我们下单。
The goods are delivered to my warehouse. The niche I have is that on a westerner. I speak English obviously. And I have the westerner. I know what products are not going to sell. I know the quality expected. It's quite an important thing, I think. I'm going to sell it. I'm in the market.
货物会被运到我的仓库。我的优势在于我是个西方人。我显然会说英语。而且我拥有西方人的思维。我知道哪些产品会卖不出去。我知道大家期望的质量。我认为这非常重要。我要把它卖掉。我在市场上。
I'm in the market. At the FUTURE market, my business is mostly bulk sales of electronic Santa Gifts. This is Wang Xiaoyang. She has a stall in the Futeon Market filled with hundreds and hundreds of plastic centers. We started this business in 1992. That's when my dad started it. Seven days a week, she's in this shop completely surrounded by centers.
我在市场上。在福田市场，我的业务主要是批量销售电子圣诞老人礼品。这是王晓阳。她在福田市场有一个摆满了数百个塑料圣诞老人的摊位。我们从1992年开始做这门生意。那是从我爸爸开始的。每周七天，她都待在这个完全被圣诞老人包围的店铺里。
Centers, surfing centers, climbing out of chimneys, centers, riding motorcycles with Ray Banzon. Before we started this business, I never heard of the concept of Christmas. I had no idea what it was. To me, Santa is a very kind old man who slides through your chimney on Christmas and brings you gifts and happiness and good fortune. Christmas is a holiday for people overseas, but for us Chinese people, we don't get any time off for it.
圣诞老人，冲浪的圣诞老人，从烟囱里爬出来的圣诞老人，骑着摩托车戴着雷朋眼镜的圣诞老人。在开始这门生意之前，我从未听说过“圣诞节”这个概念。我不知道那是什么。对我来说，圣诞老人是一个非常慈祥的老人，他在圣诞节时从你的烟囱滑下来，给你带来礼物、快乐和好运。圣诞节是海外人士的节日，但对我们中国人来说，我们不会因此放假。
Wang Xiaoyang and Nigel are just two links in the economic chain that starts in China and ends at your local dollar store. The hub of that economy is certainly the food-tien market in Iwu, but the whole Jojiang province is involved. Neighboring towns to Iwu all have their specialties. For Halloween we export which brums and there's one village that we will make these brums.
王晓阳和奈杰尔只是中国开始、当地一元店结束的这条经济链条中的两个环节。这个经济枢纽无疑是义乌的福田市场，但整个浙江省都参与其中。义乌周边的城镇都有各自的特产。对于万圣节，我们出口扫帚，有一个村子专门制作这些扫帚。
There's a town that just makes wheelbarrows. You go to a town for toys or wooden puzzles or Christmas decorations. Each town has its niche. And most of these little toys and trinkets are being produced in small operations. Maybe a family has been able to buy one piece of industrial equipment and hire a few workers. There's a scene in Daniel's film where some migrant workers are sitting around in someone's garage making cheap costume jewelry by pouring molten metal into a machine that's setting it in a mold.
有一个小镇专门生产独轮车。你会去一个专门生产玩具、木制拼图或圣诞装饰品的小镇。每个小镇都有自己的特色。而且，大多数这些小玩具和饰品都是在小型作坊里生产的。也许一个家庭能够买得起一台工业设备并雇佣几名工人。丹尼尔的电影里有一个场景，一些农民工坐在某人的车库里，把熔化的金属倒入固定在模具里的机器中，制作廉价的仿制首饰。
And then they're sort of filing it down and chucking it into a container. And then later that day, a guy will probably come by us and grab that bucket of jewelry and take it to a different part of the town where someone will put it into packaging. And then the next day, he'll come back and pick all that up and take it to the market. And for many people in the province, this isn't even their full-time day job. This is just a side business. And for many people in the province, this isn't even their full-time day job. This is just a side business. Everyone from the age of sort of 20 to 80 or 90, they'll work in the farm and then they'll
然后他们把它们打磨一番，扔进一个容器里。后来那天晚些时候，可能会有一个人来拿走那桶珠宝，把它带到镇上的另一个地方，由别人把它包装起来。第二天，他会回来把这些东西全部收走，带到市场上。对于省里的许多人来说，这甚至不是他们的全职工作。这只是一项副业。对于省里的许多人来说，这甚至不是他们的全职工作。这只是一项副业。从20岁到80岁或90岁的每个人，他们都会在农场干活，然后
come back at night and start making which is brims. A bit like the cottage industry back in industrial evolution in England. That's Nigel Crop again, the British trader who lives in Iwo. It's a great Britain, 200 years, it's taken China 20, 30 years. And you can see the effects of this super fast growth in Iwo. The city grew so quickly that it still hasn't had time to build basic infrastructure. You see, in time, neighborhoods without roads, with no paved roads, because they just need people to immediately move into these buildings and start making stuff in the basements.
晚上回来开始制作，也就是帽檐。这有点像英国工业革命时期的家庭手工业。这是奈杰尔·克罗普（Nigel Crop），住在义乌的英国商人。英国用了200年，中国只用了20、30年。你可以看到这种超高速增长在义乌产生的影响。这座城市发展太快，甚至还没来得及建立基础设施。你看，有时社区没有道路，没有铺设好的路面，因为他们只是需要人们立即搬进这些建筑里，在地下室里开始制造东西。
A few years after moving to China, Nigel met his wife, Jessie, in Iwu, local. When I started the trading company, she had a booth in the market selling bags. And also she was one of my students. Jesse's family is one of many in Iwi to benefit from China's turn toward a free market economy. Yeah, she wants me to go and eat something. Upstairs. I can't look upstairs, there's something. Got any cold beer?
搬到中国几年后，奈杰尔在义乌遇到了他的妻子杰西，她是个本地人。当我开始做贸易公司时，她在市场上有个摊位卖包。同时她也是我的学生之一。杰西的家庭是义乌众多受益于中国转向自由市场经济的家庭之一。是的，她想让我去吃点东西。在楼上。我不能看楼上有东西。有冰啤酒吗？
I've always felt part of the family. I've always accepted me. But I've always felt maybe very welcome. I've never felt any different. You got it, as well. Nigel's wife's great grandparents can remember E. Wu before it opened itself up to capitalism. We've lived here since we were born. We built our own house.
我一直觉得这是家庭的一部分。他们一直接纳我。但我一直觉得非常受欢迎。我从未感到任何不同。你也有同感。奈杰尔妻子的曾祖父母还记得义乌对外开放资本主义之前的情景。我们从出生就住在这里。我们自己盖了房子。
In the old days, it was suffering. It was really terrible. That's Nigel's great grandmother-in-law, Gong Jinxiong. Just mentioning the suffering time, I feel so that I could cry. Life was so tough that a single sweet potato was divided into pieces for several meals. In the old days, there were no cars. Now, a lot of people can afford luxurious sedans. I am so comforted by the change.
在过去，那是痛苦的。真的很糟糕。那是奈杰尔的曾祖母龚金雄。只要提到那段痛苦的时光，我就难过得想哭。生活是如此艰难，一个红薯要分成几顿吃。过去没有汽车。现在，很多人都买得起豪华轿车。这个变化让我感到无比欣慰。
Of course, capitalism has also taken its toll on China. I think globalization is ruinous. When it's unchecked, like it is in places like Iwu, you see, a landscape almost completely destroyed. You know, the mountains are all dug out. There's people burning rubbish everywhere. It's smoggy all the time. And you're sort of like, for what?
当然，资本主义也给中国带来了代价。我认为全球化是毁灭性的。当它失控时，就像在义乌这样地方，你会看到风景几乎完全被毁坏。你知道，山都被挖空了。到处都有人在烧垃圾。总是雾霾弥漫。你会想，这一切是为了什么？
And then you see why? It's people who spent years almost completely malnourished now being able to sit around with a giant family and all eat and have a lovely time. But now people in China who have been able to move out of desperate poverty want more than to just make a living. And those people are demanding a better lifestyle. We are at the market every day, every day, every day, it never changes. That's Wang Xiaoyang again.
然后你明白了原因？这是一些曾经几乎营养不良的人，现在能够和一大家子人坐在一起吃饭，度过一段美好的时光。但现在中国那些摆脱了极度贫困的人，想要的不仅仅是谋生。这些人正在要求更好的生活方式。我们每天都在市场上，每天，每天，从不改变。那是王晓阳。
Her business, Selling Santas, has grown substantially since her father first started it in 1992. It's allowed her family to move into the middle class, but it's also swallowing up her existence. She's there seven days a week from sun up to sundown.可能是每個人走過的話都會有一些遺憾 可能是每個人走過的話都會有一些遺憾可能是每個人走過的話都會有一些遺憾可能是每個人走過的話都會有一些遺憾可能是每個人走過的話都會有一些遺憾可能是每個人走過的話都會有一些遺憾可能是每個人走過的話都會有一些遺憾可能是每個人走過的話都會有一些遺憾 如果我會做得到的事 如果我會做得到的事如果我會做得到的事 我會讀一堂
她的生意——卖圣诞老人——自她父亲1992年首次创业以来有了实质性的增长。这让她的家庭得以进入中产阶级，但这也吞噬了她的全部生活。她一周七天从日出到日落都在那里。可能是每个人走过的话都会有一些遗憾 可能是每个人走过的话都会有一些遗憾可能是每个人走过的话都会有一些遗憾可能是每个人走过的话都会有一些遗憾可能是每个人走过的话都会有一些遗憾可能是每个人走过的话都会有一些遗憾可能是每个人走过的话都会有一些遗憾可能是每个人走过的话都会有一些遗憾 如果我会做得到的事 如果我会做得到的事如果我会做得到的事 我會讀一堂
如果我會讀一堂 我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會 我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會 我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會 我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會 我會不會會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會會不會我會不會會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會 我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會會不會我會不會我會不會我會不會一靠父母的街像很多的一家中美人王曉洋想了更多 我們想救了環球世界
我的 dream is to travel all around the world 第一步是要去 Egypt 這是一步我希望 每一次我去過一個人 她不想去到我家 她7天一夜一夜 她能夠把她的同事做到最終然後繼續去每一天 Sell Santa's seven days a week until she's able to get her daughter to do the same thing and then continue on forever For now though Wang Xiaoyang just has to work harder because costs in China are going up and her profit margin is getting slimmer
我的梦想是环游世界。第一步是去埃及。我希望这一步能让她的女儿做同样的事情，然后永远持续下去。不过现在，王晓阳不得不更加努力工作，因为中国的成本在上升，她的利润空间正在缩小。
You see, our costs for workers in China is increasing yearly. Every part of production, starting from the smallest fitting part to assembly costs, it's getting more and more expensive. As the cost of labor goes up, people seek out cheaper labor markets. Bangladesh, Vietnam, Laos, they're right there and they've got the facilities to do it and they're ready to take that work and they are starting to take that work away from places like you were. The Chinese government is also interested in moving the country away from its reputation as the world's factory. They don't want to be where all of our junk comes from. They want to be the next South Korea or Taiwan or Japan that makes computers and cars and solar panels and things like that. But Iwu is the city that cheap junk built, or really only half built. The city grew so fast that basic infrastructure has not caught up to the growth. In the coming years, the
你看，我们在中国的工人工资每年都在增加。生产的每一个环节，从最小的配件到组装成本，都变得越来越贵。随着劳动力成本的上升，人们开始寻找更廉价的劳动力市场。孟加拉国、越南、老挝，它们就在那里，并且拥有这样做的设施，它们准备接手这些工作，并开始从义乌这样的地方夺走这些工作。中国政府也希望改变国家作为世界工厂的声誉。他们不想成为我们所有垃圾的来源地。他们想成为下一个韩国、台湾或日本，生产电脑、汽车、太阳能电池板等产品。但义乌是廉价垃圾建成的城市，或者说只建了一半。这座城市发展太快，基础设施跟不上发展的步伐。在未来的几年里，
people of Iwu will have to find ways to finish building their city, and then new ways to survive as the global economy changes. The world's dollar stores will continue to be full of plastic sandals and cheap trinkets of all kinds, but soon this stuff may be made in the basements and garages and factories of some other city. Part 1 of 99% of Isabel was produced this week by Mitchell Johnson, edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed in tech production by Shereef Yusif, music by Sean Riel. Part 2 was produced by Katie Mingle. Kurt Colstad is the digital director of the rest of the team.
义乌人民将不得不寻找方法来完成城市的建设，并在全球经济变化的同时寻找生存的新方法。世界的美元店将继续充满各种塑料凉鞋和小玩意，但很快这些东西可能会在其他城市的地下室、车库和工厂里制造出来。《百分之九十九隐形》的第一部分由米切尔·约翰逊制作，乔·罗森伯格编辑，谢里夫·尤瑟夫混音和技术制作，肖恩·里尔配乐。第二部分由凯蒂·明格制作。库尔特·科尔斯特德是团队的数字总监。
It's Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Chris Baroube, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Additional music by Okakumi. The English voiceovers in part 2 were done by Sean Wynn and Claire Schellen. That story was adapted from the film Boclant by Daniel Wheeling and Tobias Anderson Ocarbloom. The full film is about an hour long, it includes a bunch of other interesting characters that we couldn't fit into this
这是德兰尼·霍尔、埃met·菲茨杰拉德、维维安·利、克里斯·巴鲁贝、索菲亚·克拉茨克和我罗曼·马斯。额外音乐由奥卡库米提供。第二部分的英文配音由肖恩·温和克莱尔·舍伦完成。这个故事改编自丹尼尔·惠林和托比亚斯·安德森·奥卡布姆的电影《大宗土地》。这部电影大约一个小时长，里面包含了很多我们无法融入其中的其他有趣角色
radio piece, you should really see it. It's called Bulkland, you can buy a copy of it on Amazon. 99% invisible is a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Ro. And beautiful. Downtown. Oakland, California. We are a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Support them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or run Instagram and read it too. But our home for beautiful nerds is 99PI.org.
广播节目中，你真的应该看看。它叫Bulkland，你可以在亚马逊上买到副本。《百分之九十九隐形》是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在 Radio Ro 制作。美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上支持他们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并加入有关该程序的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@Roman Mars，在 99PI 上@该节目，也可以在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上找到。但我们这些精美怪咖的家园是 99PI.org。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。